Now I will give you another type of problem and this time you can prove that this problem is
undecidable, and the problem is as follows and that problem is also one that sounds very simple.
It's the equivalence problem.  So this time, we're given two programs, P and P prime,
and the question that we want to answer is do this two programs do exactly the same thing?
For example, do they implement exactly the same algorithm only using a different type of
implementation, and now, what I would like you to do is prove that equivalence is undecidable
by showing that if you have an algorithm that would solve equivalence then you could also solve
the halting problem.  Now, the way we're going to do this quiz is as follows:
I have here six building blocks or potential building blocks of this group, and I would like you to do
the following:  There are four building blocks that you actually need for the proof and there are two
building blocks, which are not necessary for the proof.  And what I want you to do is to find out
which building blocks you need and which you don't need, and for the building blocks that you
need bring them in the right order.  So, right one next to the building blocks that would come first
in a proof of undecidability of equivalence then you write a 2 next to the next building block and so on.
It might be easier to first think of how you would prove this and then fill out the boxes
rather than playing around with them.  How you prove that equivalence is undecidable?